hola esta vez bueno esta vez no voy a
usar la página de khan academy en
español para hacer más ejemplos esta vez
lo haré un poco diferente vamos a
observar la gráfica de una función
trigonométricas y vamos a intentar
resolver bueno saber cuáles vamos a
intentar resolver la ecuación así que
iniciamos con el problema que tenemos
enfrente y bueno tenemos no sabemos que
tenemos porque bueno será una función se
no será una función coseno pero supongo
que es una en bueno es válido decir que
es una de las dos así que sería bueno
responder a la pregunta qué función
crees tú que sea ésta crees que es una
función coseno o una función seno y cuál
es la diferencia así que bojan voy a
arrastrar que una pantalla un pizarrón
virtual y mi pluma está funcionando o
qué bueno muy bien creo que sí ok
entonces bueno que es el seno de cero
seno de 0 0 grados 0 radiales seno de 0
es 0 ajá seno de 0 es igual a 0 eso eso
grava pero eso tengo siempre bien
presente que no se te olvide
ok que es coseno de 0 coseno de 0 si
recuerdas de hecho también memoriza eso
coseno de 0 es igual a 1
así que observando la gráfica en
definitiva podemos ver que cuando x es
igual a 0
puedes ver que claramente la función no
va a dar a 0 de hecho en este caso da a
1 y un medio
esto nos dice que no es una función no
es una curva para la función seno aunque
después vamos a aprender que podría ser
una curva para la función seno pero
trasladada así que bueno en esta curva
esta es una curva para la función
cosenos entonces quizás te preguntes
bueno y si es una función coseno porque
el 0 es igual a 1 y un medio en lugar de
1 porque yo acabo de decir acá que
coseno de 0 es igual a 1 eso se debe
porque debe haber aquí un coeficiente
llamado a que de hecho cambia cambia la
amplitud de la función así que a cambio
la amplitud de la curva del coseno tu
punto crees que vale ésta está
literalmente
la amplitud de la curva cual es la
amplitud de la curva si observamos
cuánto se mueve sobre y bajo el eje de
las equis es ese 1 y un medio del que
hemos estado hablando así que sube tres
medios y baja tres medios y bueno
sabemos que que es que bueno sabemos que
es tres medios coseno de algo x coseno
de algo x algo no sabemos que entonces
bueno
amd fx es igual a tres medios coseno de
algo x podríamos usar la fórmula que
usamos en el vídeo pasado decíamos que
era igual a 2000 sobre el periodo de x y
bueno ahora sólo observamos a la gráfica
y vamos a intentar averiguar cuál es el
periodo de la gráfica cuántos radiales
le tomó a la gráfica para que se repita
así que hagamos eso voy a oprimir el
botón de pista tal vez nos ayude un poco
y ahí lo tenemos dibujo el periodo así
que se iniciase en cualquier punto sigue
es la gráfica y llegas a la misma altura
podrás ver qué tan grande es su periodo
la pista en la página nos dijo que él
todo es de 4 p dibujo bueno pudiste
iniciar en cualquier punto tu por
ejemplo este baja luego baja a su vez y
vuelves a bajar y ahí está entonces
también la distancia que se recorrió
bueno el periodo es 4 p por lo tanto
bueno el periodo es 4 pib oprimo pista
otra vez y nos dirá más cosas ya sabemos
que la amplitud es de 1.5 así que voy a
boya bueno ya sabemos vamos a usar el
periodo entonces tenemos que nuestra
ecuación
fx igual a tres medios tres medios
coseno coste no de dos y sobre el
período el cuales ya sabemos en este
caso es 4x esto esto es igual a tres
medios coseno de un medio x un medio
equis y ahora sí si olvidas la fórmula
suele pasar francamente yo la órbita
todo el tiempo pero ayer la vi en un
libro así que la recordé hoy entonces
bueno
podrías pensarlo como ok
el coeficiente en el término x eso mide
cuántos ciclos la gráfica recorre en dos
radiales así que bueno voy a ver si
puedo explicarlo de una manera mejor de
una mejor manera en el contexto de este
problema
este problema se iniciamos en cero aquí
está dos pig allá abajo ahí está dos p
cuántos ciclos completamos hasta llegar
a 2 pib iniciamos aquí después vamos y
llegamos a aquí a 2 p pero solamente es
la mitad sólo fue la mitad ese es el
coeficiente en el término x y a mí me
ayudará mucho recordar eso así que
tenemos tres medios cosenos de cuántos
cuántos ciclos completo en 3 pirra dian
es sólo completo la mitad así que es un
medio de x eso es nuestra fx y bueno ya
terminamos este primer problema vamos
con vamos con otro de este mismo módulo
así que voy a vamos al siguiente
agua muy bien perfecto está interesante
porque vaya que sí porque ok solo por
inspección podemos averiguar cuánto
cuánto mide la amplitud cuánto es la
amplitud está bastante sencillo cuánto
cuánto se mueve sobre y bajo el eje de
las equis solamente uno si lo puedes ver
así que por lo tanto por lo tanto la
amplitud o lo que multiplica la función
ya sea seno coseno cualquiera que sea es
uno la amplitud es igual a uno y ahora
intentamos averiguar si es una función
seno o josé no en el último problema
observamos que seno de cero es igual a
cero y que cose 90 es igual a 1
efe de 0 en esta función en este caso es
0 por lo tanto sabemos que es una
función seno no trasladada y ahí tenemos
más información entonces voy a
escribirlo lo voy a escribir este
amplitud igual a 1 y función seno ahora
lo último que tenemos que averiguar es
el periodo podemos usar el método que te
acabo de mostrar en el vídeo paso bueno
no más bien en en el ejercicio pasado
hace unos cuantos minutos
y cuántas veces se completa un ciclo en
dos radiales la pregunta clave que
debemos hacernos hagamos nos veamos
bueno de hecho esta gráfica nos llega a
2 pero no sucede está bien aquí ya se
completó un ciclo después serían dos
ciclos en solo pi radiales entonces si
yo complete dos ciclos en pi radiales en
dos radiales serán el doble cuatro
ciclos podríamos de hecho iniciar en
menos pi ajá entonces de menos pi api
eso es 2 piray danés tenemos un ciclo
dos ciclos tres ciclos cuatro ciclos y
entonces tenemos seno de 4x y ahora
tenemos fx igual a 1 por la amplitud es
el coeficiente que va a multiplicar al
la función seno entonces seno de 4x y
creo que tenemos tiempo para otro
ejercicio pero es importante que no
hagas esto mecánicamente lo que te digo
quiero que piensen porque es válido
porque porque hay que contar cuántos
ciclos en 2 pirra dian eso piensa en el
círculo unitario porque tiene sentido
todo esto o la fórmula dos pieces sobre
el periodo x que hay con eso porque
tiene sentido porque es válido entonces
el reto es que tú buscas para que para
que así no tengas que memorizarlo y
puedas hacerlo 20 años después así que
bueno podría llegar a esas fórmulas y
hagamos otro ejemplo para para dejar
todo más claro hagamos otro ejemplo
genial perfecto ok
pues la amplitud de esta función cuál es
la amplitud ahí podemos ver que es como
un medio menos de hecho es un medio y
voy a voy a borrar lo que tengo aquí por
alguna razón no me deja borrarlo ahí
está ok entonces la amplitud es igual a
un medio la amplitud es igual a un medio
oír cuántos ciclos en cuanto ciclos
completa se completan en dos radiales si
iniciamos aquí en el cero parece que
sólo se completa la mitad de un ciclo
cierto ahí está la mitad de un ciclo
porque le tomó cuatro y radiales
completar todo un ciclo y así que sólo
completa la mitad
y podemos pensarlo de dos maneras
podemos decir que el periodo es igual a
4 p ese es el tiempo que tarda en
completar un ciclo o decir que solo solo
completa la mitad de un ciclo en 2 pirra
dian es así que bueno ahora lo último
que debemos averiguar es si es una
función seno coseno efe de 0 es igual a
0 por lo tanto es una función seno no
trasladada y terminamos ahí ya tenemos
entonces fx es igual a un medio seno
seno de que a cuantos ciclos completo en
dos radiales sólo la mitad entonces
puedes ver que es fx es igual a un medio
seno de un medio equis o usando la
fórmula tenemos dos pistas sobre el
período x entonces tendríamos tenemos
aquí dos p2 pi sobre el período dos pies
sobre el período eso es igual
a dos pisos sobre cuatro pib lo cual es
igual a un medio así que ahí lo tienes
ahí tienes las herramientas necesarias
para sobrevivir a este tipo de problemas
hay ejercicios en la página de khan
academy en español y bueno te invito a
que los hagas nos vemos